welcome back
so I'm really excited in this next short
sequence to walk you through a machine
learning primer so essentially giving
you the building blocks the kind of nuts
and bolts of how machine Learning Works
how you build a model really
demystifying machine learning so that
you can see kind of how these models are
built how they're trained what are the
types of models that allow us to do the
amazing things we've seen like you know
image classification large language
models and so on so I'm going to dive in
with an overview of all of the types of
machine learning and kind of what it
means and then we'll talk about neural
networks in particular what's the
difference between classification and
clustering it's supervised and
unsupervised learning things like that
kind of show this joke movie
really to give this idea that often when
I talk about machine learning to a
general audience there is this feeling
that machine learning is Magic and
there's this great Arthur C Clarke quote
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable for magic so my iPhone
to some extent is Magic to me because
you know I take it for granted it does
amazing things and I don't really know
how I know enough that I know that it's
built on you know transistors and
antennas and there's a battery and
there's software like it's not totally
magic but it can sure feel like magic
and so what we want to do is rapidly
demystify what we mean by Machine
learning
I'm going to oversimplify
that machine learning in general is just
the process of building models from data
and typically we use either optimization
or regression algorithms to build those
models from data
now when we say it this way it
demystifies what machine learning is
machine learning is just kind of input
output models that perform some task
and they are trained from Real World
data using optimization and regression
algorithms okay
it's not 100 true but that's close
enough to True most of the time that
it's a good working definition and we've
been building models from data for
decades okay so this this is something
that we understand how to do even though
machine learning is new and interesting
because we have so much more data and so
much better optimization algorithms and
so much more representative and and
flexible models like neural networks
that we can finally train on on high
performance Computing architectures the
idea of building models from data is
something that makes sense to us
and typically we build these models from
data by solving an optimization problem
and again most of our engineering tasks
that we think about in a daily basis
like modeling design sensing estimation
control at the end of the day those are
hard optimization problems that have the
same characteristics of you know High
dimensional non-convex characteristics
that most machine learning models have
when we train them when we train a deep
neural network it's also High
dimensional and non-convex and so these
really do go very well together that we
can use tools for machine learning to
solve engineer and optimization problems
and that's a very exciting and rapidly
growing area of both science and
engineering
good so uh what is a model I said that
machine learning is the process of
building models from data
a model is essentially I think of it as
a function that takes in input data and
there are some output values that humans
care about and the inner guts of how
that function evaluates that input
output model there's a million different
ways you could represent that model in a
computer in a program as a function but
at the end of the day it's an input
output program so in this example the
input data might be a high resolution
image of either a dog or a cat this is
our dog Mordecai
and the input data would get fed into
the model the model would be some
function of X where X is my input data
and this model would do do a number of
computations on that data it might you
know run a little convolutional filter
across it it might look for ears and
snouts who knows what it does it might
be some complicated function and after
doing all of this numerical evaluation
at the output is going to be some
desired output so for example if I'm
trying to build a classifier that tells
dogs and cats apart then my output might
be a two Vector with my probability of
it being a dog and the probability of it
being a cat and if I do a really good
job when I put in an image of mort the
dog then this Vector should return a one
zero because it's very confident that
it's a dog okay that's the kind of model
we're talking about with machine
learning and again the inner guts don't
have to be a neural network you could
use a decision tree a random Forest a
support Vector machine there's lots of
different ways of training this input
output function of representing this
input output function
it turns out neural networks are one of
the most flexible ways of representing
functions and so they're very widely
used today but neural networks is not
all that there is to machine learning so
that's a really important thing to take
away as well
um I got this example in this image from
my friend Nathan Kutz and I really like
this ever since he presented this
example um it's been in my head this
Picasso quote computers are useless they
can only give you answers I think that's
such an insightful connection Nathan
made between this Picasso quote and
machine learning it's the same with
machine learning machine learning is
useless it can only give you model
outputs you're the one who has to decide
what are you trying to model what are
the inputs and what are the outputs of
that model okay and so there's still a
lot of human expertise and human
guidance in this procedure in this
process of building these machine
learning models you get to design the
architecture you get to design what the
model is trying to achieve you get to
curate the training data and how the
optimization is run these are all human
questions that have to be asked before
you can get the machine to generate
those answers for you
so there are many types of machine
learning and this is again only uh
paltry classification into all of the
different types there aren't there are
more types of machine learning than just
what I'm showing you you hear but this
is a rough categorization so some of the
big breakdowns uh are between supervised
and unsupervised algorithms and I'll
talk a lot more about those later but
the idea is supervised algorithms the
training data has labels so if I have a
bunch of images of dogs and cats and I'm
trying to build a classifier if all of
those training data images are labeled
by hand someone labeled them this is a
dog this one's a cat this one's another
dog if they're labeled then the machine
learning algorithm that you develop to
tell dogs and cats apart is a classifier
okay so supervised learning has labels
and if I want to tell dogs and cats
apart from labels I would build a
classifier lots of techniques to do that
support Vector machines decision trees
random forests neural networks is a very
powerful way we do this today but
there's lots of options depending on how
much data you have have what types of
data you have how interpretable you want
it to be things like that
um in the unsupervised world when I
don't have labels if I give you just a
mountain of images of dogs and cats but
I don't tell you which one's which you
might still be able to pull information
out of that mountain of data and tell
that there are these two large
categories of different animals but
without the labels this would be more of
a clustering algorithm maybe I would
learn a cluster that mostly corresponds
to dogs and another cluster that mostly
corresponds to cats but it's a different
task this is more like data mining from
that data what are the patterns without
knowing the labels
and then there's a lot of stuff in the
middle that we call kind of
semi-supervised where there's partial
knowledge or partial labels or some of
the data is labeled things like
reinforcement learning and generative
models typically are in this kind of
nebulous Middle Ground here and again
we'll talk more about all of these but I
just wanted you to know that there are
lots of different types of machine
learning and it usually depends on what
kind of data you have and what your task
is with that data
so before I end this uh kind of piece of
this module on on the machine learning
primer I just want to talk very at an
abstract level what goes into training
and building a machine learning model
okay so machine learning is the process
of building models from data usually by
solving an optimization problem and so I
want to kind of just very briefly walk
through these steps because later
we remember we are engineers and
scientists we are going to be doing
physics informed machine learning and
building physical models from data so I
want you to understand all of the stages
and remember you're going to be able to
put physics you're going to be able to
bake your prior knowledge of the physics
and engineering principles into all of
these steps
remember go back to that Picasso quote
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide on the question you're
asking you're after you have to decide
on the objective what are we actually
modeling what are the inputs and the
outputs of my machine learning model
given what data what decision do I want
the model to make based on that data
that's a human thing to decide this is
where a human expertise goes into
deciding the subjective
the second piece of this training is you
have to get training data it's not
machine learning if you're not building
this model from training data so what
data will inform the model what training
data do you have access to is it labeled
or not does it have the output of the
function that you're looking for what is
the data I'm going to to use here
the third step and this is kind of like
the exciting step that a lot of
attention goes into is designing the
architecture am I going to use a neural
network if so which type of neural
network am I using a recurrent neural
network or an autoencoder am I going to
use a linear regression technique like
DMD what is the actual architecture I'm
going to use to represent that input
output function so I've decided on a
function
now I'm going to decide what is the
architecture that could possibly
represent the input output relationship
that I'm trying to learn is it a
recurrent neural network or an
autoencoder or so on and so forth
once we have an architecture so this is
kind of an example of an architecture
it's a specific neural network with a
specific shape and structure that I
think might be good for learning certain
types of input output relationships
and once I've done that now I get to
write down a loss function or an
objective function that I'm going to
optimize over
so this is how we tell if a model is
good or bad is how well it scores on
this loss function so low loss is better
High loss is bad and so what I'm going
to be doing is writing down essentially
a mathematical expression
in terms of my data and my input output
function how well it matches the
training data that tells me if my model
did a good job or a bad job
and then finally we actually have to
employ some optimization algorithm maybe
I have to write my own optimization
algorithm or maybe I use an
off-the-shelf Optimizer that essentially
minimizes this loss function by changing
the weights tuning the weights of this
architecture to best fit the data to
satisfy this objective
so this is all kind of a big procedure
here that fits together you have to
choose what you're modeling you have to
find data that will inform that model
you pick an architecture that you think
can represent the function you're trying
to approximate you write down a loss
function or an objective function that
tells if you did a good job after the
training and then you optimize the
weights of the architecture to minimize
that loss function over the data okay
that's the whole procedure of machine
learning in a nutshell and all of these
pieces are ripe with opportunities for a
human expert to come in and flavor and
steer this process this is not an
automated process this is not TurnKey no
matter how much it looks like it from
the outside machine learning is a human
endeavor this is a tool for humans to
model the real world from actual data
and we get to guide all of these steps
and the last point is
if I have a physical system if I have a
system governed by f equals m a or some
kind of engineering first principles I
often have opportunities to put in those
first principles in each of these stages
and make my machine learning model
better and More Physical by construction
that's called physics informed machine
learning and we're definitely going to
talk about that in the context of
Engineering Systems that's where there's
a huge opportunity to really
dramatically improve machine learning
for physical systems and also to get
lots more like performance and insights
out of those you know maybe I want my
model to be energy conservative if I'm
modeling a fluid flow I get to put that
into different stages of this process
okay that's it for the overview we're
going to start diving into what is a
neural network what are those
differences between you know supervised
and unsupervised learning and how do I
add physics into this process that's all
coming up thank you